hi there steve kaufman i want to talk
about juggling languages or using modern
technology to learn languages the way i
couldn't have done 50 years ago
i am focused on three languages
korean
ukrainian and russian
korean because i've i want to improve my
korean i've
dabbled in it
so much and yet i'm
you know still not where i want to be
korean or at least ukrainian
i'm basically where i want to be i
understand 80
so i will gradually understand more and
more and russian it's more a matter of
following things of interest to me
but i am spending time on these three
languages primarily what do i do and how
do i do it it's interesting because i
think it's an indication of what modern
technology makes possible so let's start
with korean with korean
i have in my system easier content that
we have at our library at link and so
forth but i don't find it interesting
that easy content i can understand i
also have on my
little ipod nano in korean i have a
bunch of sort of
basic phrases a book that i mentioned
before that i bought in japan with cd
you know hundreds of little phrases in
korean that i've listened to many many
times to give me a sense of the basic
structure
you can only listen to those for so much
and then they get uninteresting and when
you when the interest dies you stop
learning
i refer again to
the
comment in manfred spitzer's book i
called something about the brain and
learning the brain needs repetition but
the brain needs novelty it has to be
interesting so
i can no longer listen to those
uh basic korean phrases i can no longer
listen to the easy content in our
library so i have found now a new
podcast not kim yong-ha which is on
literature and which is sometimes too
difficult but one on current events
shisa tong
so i go to shiseidon i download their
podcast it's 40 50 minutes long
i have now gone to the same transcriber
who transcribed king young kim young
podcast on literature and she has
started transcribing these for me if i
have right now i have one 40-minute
podcast which i have divided into 10 or
12-minute segments
uh i listen
don't understand or understand very
little
then i
read it
on my computer
because there i have access to the naver
dictionary i can look up the meaning i
can look up the
characters the chinese characters if
available i put those into
link
and then i go away and i read this on my
ipad
now the ipad
our link app in ipad
has the advantage
that
we can look at it
uh sentence by sentence
see if i can get this
you know the sentence changes every time
i touch the button and so and it
remembers where i am because even a 10
or 12
um
text in korean for me it's still quite
difficult and i prefer to read it
sentence by sentence
and that remembers where i am and then
i'll i'll work my way through the 40
minutes worth of text and i've been
listening to this text quite a few times
not really understanding much but the
more i read the better i understand
so
i listen on my ipod nano
i work through them on my i link on my
ipad reading
but because we're down here in palm
springs and my wife likes to play golf
she likes to shop so i'm often with her
either i'm waiting
at the golf course for the people to
uh you know tee off or i'm waiting in a
store so then
on
my
iphone
i can review the flash cards which is an
activity that
you know if i have dedicated study time
i really don't like doing flash cards
but
if i am
just standing around
then you know i can do my flash cards
and that's a great way to do and the way
i do flash cards is
i put the korean
term
the translation and the
link captured phrase all in the front i
don't challenge myself to try to
remember it i just go through them and
it's just another form of exposure so i
use those three things one other thing i
do
i managed i discovered this little
uh bluetooth loudspeaker
it's
this big
so very often like when we're having
dinner here i will uh play some music
from my iphone or from my ipod nano but
uh my wife certainly doesn't want to
listen to korean uh while we're eating
uh anytime i'm listening to korean or
russian or ukrainian i put on my
earphones and of course nowadays you
have
um
bluetooth
bluetooth earphones like these that i
bought that are just phenomenal
but if i'm gonna have a bath or
something or if i'm doing exercises here
i ruined my back so i've got to do these
back exercises three times a day
it's just as easy to throw this down
and listen while doing those exercises
so i mean look at the technology we got
the ipod nano we got ipad not to mention
the computer
uh iphone for flashcards this for casual
listening all using bluetooth
technology
um
by the way where did the flash cards
come from the flashcards come from the
words that i have saved which i save on
the computer which are then highlighted
in yellow so that uh you know when i
read them on my
ipad
uh you know i can just touch them and
see what the meaning is and all this
kind of stuff
so
now so with korean that's the routine
now with ukrainian with korean if i
listen to shi satong i understand 10 15
20
with ukrainian i understand depending on
the context 85 percent uh but there's
still words there that i want to learn
so with korean or at least with
ukrainian
i download podcasts from
most
frequently from romance radio and
they're very interesting interviews
there there they don't offer
um
transcripts however i also go to radio
swaboda where they will occasionally
have
an interview with a transcript so i will
download those
but i also import a lot of content
that's as i said before from uh
ukrainian pravda from uh wherever i can
find it or references that i get on my
twitter feed and i read through those
and save words and phrases on the
computer or on the ipad
uh
with ukrainian and russian i can do all
of the linking on the ipad because i'm
not looking to get
you know uh
chinese characters or anything like that
the dictionary works fine on the ipad
so with ukrainian i guess i do a little
more reading than listening but a bit of
both with russian i basically just
listen because 95
i get there's the odd word that i don't
get if i'm really interested uh then i
will import the text from echo must be
where as i've said before you always
have transcript with audio a tremendous
source right now there's some pressure
on ecommerce fee
which is to my mind quite unfair because
you can find a number of different
political positions that echo must be
people who support the government who
oppose the government and it's all their
audio with transcript tremendous
resource for russian learners so that's
how i use all this different stuff
and the way i listen course differs if
i'm listening to the korean where i
understand 10 15 20
i am motivated because i'm trying to
understand more and and and now i
clearly hear the words but they're words
that i don't yet know
or they're words that in fact i do know
but i'm not able yet to recognize them
when i hear them uh whereas i do
understand when i read because
any missing words i can look up uh by
you know touching the screen and so that
the whole context is clearer and as i
continue working this uh shisatong
podcast that i've had transcribed i will
eventually get to where i understand it
when it's spoken by that time my
transcriber will have another podcast
done for me and i continue the process
uh when i listen to ukrainian or russian
i'm essentially listening for the
meaning i'm interested in the events in
ukraine i'm interested hearing different
opinions so
i'm just listening for for or reading
for interest and in that process
gradually improving my skills now i do
dabble in some other languages just if
someone for example on my twitter feed
sends me to an interesting article in
german
and i've done so little work on link
uh in german
in some ways my vocabulary in russian is
better than my vocabulary in german
although i speak german better than
russian so i'll grab the article
put it on link and save the blue words
the unknown words and
gradually kind of putting stuff away in
my in my german area for you know
it's just part of keeping that alive and
particularly recently in prague where
there were some events surrounding
statements made by their president and
some demonstration against the president
i've been reading some articles in czech
and
also uh reactivated my subscription or
my r
rrs feed to uh cesky roslas and listen
to a discussion about politics and
uh czech republic but that's very much
minor
but again i was doing that
in czech
while having a bath and i was listening
to it on my little
uh bluetooth portable speaker
so there you have it running through so
getting back this listening thing just
before i finish to me listening is
tremendously powerful
in terms of language learning and never
has it been easier than today
when i listen to things that i don't
understand i am motivated to try to pick
up pick out notice
more and more of it but i'd like to
eventually get to a transcript
so i will listen to
say in the case of korean some content
for which there is no transcript but
eventually i reach a dead end i've
listened to it a few times i've picked
up a few more words but i'm not
understanding any more of it in order to
progress i've got to get a transcript so
that's korean so
but i'm motivated
one other thing people wonder about you
know don't you sort of fade in fade out
of course i do you can't be 100 focused
the other thing is
i don't listen as a dedicated activity i
think i would fade out more if i did
if i have dedicated learning time i read
i save links
listening is when i am doing other
things
and they're sure you fade in and out but
it's all exposure to the language
so with material where you don't
understand much you're listening to try
to grasp the definitions not the
definition but the limitation between
words pick up the odd word but
ultimately i want to get to a transcript
when i'm listening to material where i
understand 70 80 90
i'm listening for enjoyment but even
there if i can get to a transcript and
pick up those words that i'm missing
save them now they're going to be
showing up in yellow when i subsequently
read eventually they'll be part of my
at first passive vocabulary and possibly
eventually active vocabulary so there
you have it juggling languages
in the modern
language learning environment i hope
that's useful and i look forward to your
questions bye for now